[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle finally I
arrived in Seoul South Korea and I
showed you a little bit around the city
and I also introduced you to a few new
friends this is the Giorgio Armani
campaign so hey my name is Elizabeth I'm
from France
oh yeah yeah of course and finally I
took you with me behind the scenes to
record TV commercial for an online game
called black desert what is that
[Music]
so we're gonna take the train I'm not
gonna bore you guys with showing you
everything but I think we're just gonna
teleport right to the seafood market oh
yeah
all right that was fast
we're here we are at the fish market and
we're gonna look around a little bit
smells fishy check it out
[Music]
this place is big yeah electric electric
a lot of crabs here oh look at those big
crabs
oh they're big this place is huge look
it goes on forever and if you turn like
aquarium yeah and if you look that way
it just continues on and on and on oh my
goodness this Lobster yeah that one is a
[Music]
all right where are we going
Maya we have to use a GPS in here that's
how big it is I don't even know what
this what is this I have no idea what
this is
worms look at this have you seen that
before him
this is not for sensitive viewers what
is that look
I think I think that's big enough
they're still alive yeah they are very
alive so the idea is you come here you
choose what you want to eat and then you
pay them and then they go upstairs to
where they have the restaurant and then
they prepare the food for you there but
I don't think it's gonna take them a lot
to prepare the octopus because we have
to eat it while it's still moving but I
did take some salmon for backup
if I don't like it are we gonna have
some salmon
they gave it to her and they're gonna
show us to the restaurant and we're
gonna eat it there we need to follow her
I'm gonna have some dried fish here
place is so big I don't know where to
look it's just everything is so
interesting yeah I want us you want to
see everything at the same time there
he's so cool
where are we Wow
I don't know what to think I'm starting
to feel a bit nervous because I think
things moving my mouth while I eat it
it's not something that I'm used but
grown-ups disco eats and Alive tentacles
whoa how do you feel about that no
what'd she do it said they are taking
some of the food these are all the
restaurants up here my goodness this
place is big
[Music]
all right so these are the side dishes
we have Olivia
[Music]
you outside agra fees that you are brave
yeah I got to take a video this
so we're gonna have to try this put it
into our mouths maybe maybe you should
show us how we should do
meet Ryan abroad I need to watch it
reversed and then I'll give it a try
that big one yeah that's holding on to
the place
so in the sauce
how is it yeah it's a fight
he's seeking a homicidal cheek so I then
Maya has a really good poker face or he
really likes it I'm gonna stick to my
rice you're not gonna try okay I'm gonna
try get my chopsticks over here
and it wasn't strong enough
my is loving it okay which one the most
lively one rs1 yes yes nice the big yes
so you want me to try for the gram and
chew it don't you
[Music]
he's fighting
grabbing on to the son of Mohammed
you need to back up now you need to get
some sauce in there all right we are
done
I don't think I will do it again it's
not for me why I love that something
that she really loves I had the salmon
is backup the salmon placed in great
but Alex didn't try he said there's no
way he's gonna do that he'll stick with
rice rice is good but that's it we did
it another experience we can mark it off
the list that's it